(swoosh)
- [Narrator] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website, or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(gentle fun music)
- Welcome to A Conversation With History.
I'm Harry Kreisler of the Institute
of International Studies.
Our guest today is
Harriet Mayor Fulbright,
who is the Harvest
distinguished woman lecturer
on the Berkeley campus this semester.
And she is a co-founder of
the Harriet Mayor Fulbright College.
She served in the Clinton Administration
as executive director
of President Clinton's
committee on the arts and the humanities.
And she has been an unofficial ambassador
for the Fulbright Program.
Mrs. Fulbright, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you so much, I'm glad to be here.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in New York City.
My father was a, on the
business end of Time Magazine,
and he was constantly opening new offices.
So we did a fair amount of moving.
- And looking back, how did your parents
shape your thinking about the world?
- They shaped it fundamentally
because my father
really strongly believed in
connections around the world
as the only way we were
going to be saved, in fact.
So there was constant conversation,
even when I was little,
about other parts of the world.
And in fact he sent me to
Latin America when I was 15.
- And what about your
mother, what was her--
- My mother was unfortunately killed
in a skiing accident when I was 12.
And that was very hard on the
family as you can imagine.
I was the oldest of
four, and I was only 12.
But he did marry a couple of years later,
a wonderful woman, who is still alive
and who became an integral
part of our family.
- Did you wind up
traveling with your father
or living abroad when you
were still very young?
- Yes, he was actually,
his home was physically moved to places.
We started in New York,
moved to Philadelphia.
During the second world
war we lived in Washington.
Then he moved to Europe, Paris.
By that time I was not, I was in college
and I wasn't with the family all the time,
but yes, I obviously
visited him as he moved.
- And where did you do
your undergraduate work?
- My undergraduate work
was at Radcliffe College,
and graduated from there.
- And what did you major in?
- International relations.
- And did you do a study abroad,
or did they have study abroad then?
- It was a very narrow and
difficult type of program,
so no, I did not study abroad, there,
and didn't feel particularly the need to
since my (laughs) family was
educating me in that fashion.
- And so, out of college, what
career choice did you make?
Or is, is that when you,
when did you have this,
your first living abroad,
education abroad experience?
- That was, I guess, when I (sighs)
I was in my 20s, I believe.
I lived for two years in the Soviet Union.
And that was quite an
extraordinary experience.
- And this would have been,
what years approximately?
- In 19', let's see, in the 1950s.
- In the 1950's, and what was that like,
cause that must have been
at the height of the cold war and--
- [Harriet] It was the
height of the cold war.
- What, were you afraid?
- I wasn't afraid, I was frustrated.
I knew we were going, this
was with my first husband,
and I knew we were going to live there.
And so I studied Russian very hard.
And I'm pretty good at languages,
so when I got there I could
make normal conversation.
I traveled to keep my sanity,
and some of those travels
were quite extraordinary,
and made me realize that this
regime's days were numbered.
- And was there a lot of interaction with
the people of the Soviet Union?
- Only surreptitiously.
There was one time when
I took a trip to Tashkent
to visit schools, and at one
point the student teachers,
when I tried to leave that afternoon,
went to the principal and said,
"We have to show that we're polite.
"We have to escort her back to her hotel."
And as soon as I got to the sidewalk,
they said, "Where do
you really want to go?"
(both laughing)
And it was an incredible evening.
- So the beginnings of
the dissident movement
were apparent to anybody
who talked to the people.
- Yes, and it was clear
that there was no way
that it could last, because
at the end of that evening,
one of the young men, pulled
out this Time Magazine,
and smoothed it out,
and there was a picture
of an apartment building,
American apartment building.
He said, "You see that picture?"
And I said, "Yes."
And he said, "You see
what the name of it is?"
And it, I, it was an apartment building
that was marked slums.
He said, "To us, that's a
nice apartment building.
"What else are they lying to us about?"
I thought, oh boy, deep trouble.
- So now, when was your
education abroad experience in Columbia?
Was that--
- That was when I was only 15.
And I was in high school, of course.
And I spent three solid months in Bogota,
and went to the Gimnasio Femenino.
And that was in order to
not just improve my Spanish,
but to realize how very different life
was in other countries.
- And so in both cases, you
acquired some language skills.
- Oh yes.
- [Harry] Yeah.
- Oh yes, I spoke Russian
and I did speak Spanish, yes.
- And and so, did this, shall we say,
get you the foreign
travel, foreign education
abroad bug very early?
- Oh yes.
- So you wanted to do more and so on.
- [Harriet] Yes.
- And what were you doing after
you graduated from college
beyond going to these--
- Well at that point
- [Harry] Places?
- My first husband was a
foreign service officer.
- [Harry] I see.
- So after two years in Washington,
we moved and I spent two years in Korea,
and I immediately went
to try to find work.
And I taught English and creative writing
at Ewha Womens University.
- Which is in Korea?
- Yes, South Korea.
- [Harry] Right.
- Yes, in Seoul.
- [ Harry] So you were
building up quite a portfolio
at a very young age.
- Right.
- Did you learn Korean then?
- Oh yes.
- [Harry] Some Korean.
- I did, yes, I worked at it very hard.
I hate being in a place where
I don't know what's going on.
I can't, you know.
- And Korea must have been
a very different place
back then.
- [Harriet] Primitive.
Cause there was still a dictatorship.
- Actually, Syngman Rhee had just fled
to Hawaii when I arrived,
and they were thrilled
with their newfound freedom.
And I did get a job at the Korea Times,
which was their English language paper,
and I corrected their English.
- And, but the economic
miracle had not occurred then.
- No, no, they were just
beginning to get off their feet
and beginning to build.
- I'm curious, what your
conclusion then and now is
about what the skills required
for being an education abroad student.
Obviously language.
- But you also have to have an open mind.
The open mind is equally as
important as the language.
Because, perhaps it's not
quite so different now
because we are, you know,
communication is so extraordinary.
I'll never forget one of
the first conversations
I had in the school in Bogota
when I was able to converse.
They asked me why I didn't do this
at the beginning of every class.
And I said because I'm not a
Catholic, I'm a Protestant,
and they looked at me, and they said,
"Oh, do you believe in God?"
You know, the ignorance on
both sides was just enormous.
- So, at one level being
abroad for the first time
is disorienting.
- [Harriet] True.
- And so it requires navigation
- [Harriet] Correct.
- of your environment.
And I guess, I'm curious
about the emotional side.
In the beginning, you're
intimidated, I guess.
You're taken aback.
But then as you learn to
respect what you're seeing.
Does that--
- That does change.
- [Harry] You evolve.
- Completely.
- Yes.
I think maybe intimidated,
is a little strong.
I think you realize that you
have to watch what you say
because it could be so
easily misinterpreted.
And you're trying to make connections,
and so you're asking more questions.
- Cautious, cautious.
- [Harriet] Yes.
You're very cautious
- Cautious.
- Exactly.
- And is it by getting to
know people, making friends,
interacting both socially and
whatever you're doing there
that you find their humanity?
- You find their humanity.
- [Harry] And your own I guess.
- And your own, and you
find that their differences
are not threatening,
but simply differences.
- And so, what, is it better to come
with the language skills, or
when you're immersed in a society,
can you just pick that up?
- I think you have to have a
modicum of language skills.
I think you have to
have a way of, at least
stumbling through
introductions and connections.
Because otherwise what
are you, just a post.
- And in the case of, while
you were young in Bogota,
you were a little older
in the Soviet Union.
In both cases, had you been exposed
to the history or the culture.
- I exposed myself.
- [Harry] Before you got--
- Yes.
- [Harry] But before you actually went?
- Yes, yes.
- And was there a lotta difference
from what you read in the books
to what you were experiencing?
- Not that much, the
books were pretty good
about describing what society was like,
and what their modes of living were.
- What about the temperament of a person
who aspires to be a
foreign exchange student,
both then and now?
I guess now it's easier.
- Much easier.
- But when you were doing
it, this foreign territory,
was really foreign territory.
- [Harriet] It was totally
foreign, it was totally foreign.
- So what is required?
- [Harriet] An open mind.
- Open mind.
- And a willingness to ask
all kinds of questions.
And a willingness to give of yourself,
and realize that sometimes
you might be misunderstood.
But that's what it is, a misunderstanding.
It's not hostility.
- But, so then, in your
time, it was about courage.
Courage, is that the right word?
- I guess that's a good word.
- [Harry] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Harry] Patience?
- Patience was essential.
Of yourself as well as others.
- Right, and did you then
experience a lot of frustration?
- Of course, yes.
- Now, to what extent do you think,
now we'll talk about
foreign exchange generally
in a minute but, do you think
from your own experience,
it would have made you
a better negotiator?
Because people are always talking about
knowing your adversary, or
knowing the person you have,
do you agree with that,
based on that experience?
- Yes, I think so.
And not only patience but a
large amount of understanding
because a lot of the
hostility of people who come
from foreign lands is
simply they don't understand
where they're coming from.
- Now when you went, you were American.
- [Harriet] Oh, Yes.
- America was all-powerful.
- [Harriet] Yes.
- In the world.
How did that, do you think in retrospect,
impacted the way you were received?
In other words, did, I guess in a way,
discovering your humanity for the other
made it a step toward better understanding
in the United States, a little step.
- I think that when, when we got talking
and they realized that I
really did know something
and respected their society, then I became
a human being rather than an American.
And that made a huge difference.
- And would they, they would ask you,
you used the example
of the apartment house
in Time Magazine.
So there must have been
a stream of questions.
- Definitely.
- [Harry] Coming at you about movies,
about restaurants.
- Yes.
- [Harry] About all sorts of things.
- Yes, yes, and I welcomed
them because, you know,
and admitted, you know, our shortcomings,
which, Lord knows, we had then
and every country still does.
- And, of course now,
a student goes abroad,
and they can Skype their family back home.
They can use a computer and
use face time and so on.
But that was a very different world.
You were there, and you were there.
- [Harriet] That's correct.
- So was it all letter writing back home?
- It was all letter writing.
There was nothing else,
I mean computers, no.
They didn't operate that way.
So we'd always add lag time (chuckles)
- Now, later in life, you married
Senator William Fulbright.
- [Harriet] That's right.
- And let's talk about him,
as a political leader, a
distinguished statesman,
before we talk about his political and--
- [Harriet] Okay.
- Talk a little about him
as a personality because
he's obviously a very
important historical figure
in the consciousness and
the history of this country.
- He was an amazing human being.
And I met him because of the
fact that two friends of mine
knew that I had just
come off an important job
at the National Gallery, and they said,
"This is going to be
really different, Harriet,
"but it's equally important.
"We want you to start
an alumni association
"for the Fulbright Program."
And it was a huge job because, you know,
there were records, thousands of records
that I had to gather from
separate colleges and so forth.
But it was an idea whose time
was really, had really come.
People welcomed it, and so,
my job was trying to keep up with
the enthusiastic responses
that were coming in.
- And this is how you
met Senator Fulbright?
- Of course.
- [Harry] Right.
- And he was so pleased
that this was happening.
- And was he a, he obviously was a very,
he was both a political
leader, a statesman,
but he was also something
of an intellectual.
- He was a tremendous intellectual.
He'd had a Rhodes Scholarship.
He'd spent at least two years in England.
And the Rhodes set up these tutorials.
He was working with one
particular professor, McCallum,
at Oxford, and it was intense.
He told me it was the most intense
educational experience that he'd ever had.
- And so he was born
and raised in Arkansas,
and then he, as a young
man, was a Rhodes Scholar.
This would have been in the '30s?
- That's right, Yes.
- [Harry] Yeah, yeah.
- And he traveled, obviously,
by train to New York City,
in order to catch a boat,
and New York shocked him to the core.
He never got over that (laughs).
- Because he was from--
- [Harriet] Fayetteville.
- Yeah, so
(Harriet laughing)
- I was looking for the word.
So he had been raised
in a provincial setting.
- Definitely, I mean,
the houses in his city
at that time were two stories, you know?
- [Harry] Right.
- And there he arrived at
this extraordinary city,
that was full of noise and
rushing and eight million people.
- And do you know how he happened to apply
for the Rhodes--
- Yes, it was in his senior year.
He was a very good student.
- And he was a student at
the University of Arkansas?
- Arkansas, and his English
professor came and said,
"What are you gonna do when you leave?"
"Well, I don't know."
And so he said, "You should
apply for a Rhodes Scholarship."
And he looked into it and he said,
"Well, that's interesting."
And he talked to his
family and they thought
it was a wonderful idea.
He had a wonderful mother,
especially his father died early.
And, so he applied and he got it.
- And so, and then when he
came, he came back to Arkansas.
- Yes.
- [Harry] Let me ask you this--
- But it was a hiatus.
He came back and landed in Washington.
- [Harry] I see.
- And he met a very attractive young lady
and decided he wanted to
spend a little time here.
So he applied for a job,
and became a professor there
for a couple of years before going back.
- And his field was history?
Or Government?
- It's constitutional law.
- Constitutional law.
So did he get the law
degree as a Rhodes Scholar?
Or did he come back and do that?
- Came back and did that in Washington.
- [Harry] I see, and where did he do that?
- George Washington University.
- [Harry] George Washington
University, okay.
- That's where he got his law degree.
- So, and, but then he
went back to Arkansas.
- [Harriet] Yes, he did.
- And became--
- A professor.
- [Harry] President of the--
- But first a professor,
and then president.
- Right, and was that for two years.
- [Harriet] Yes.
- And then he ran for
the Senate, was that--
- No, he ran for an
office in the legislature.
He actually had a former
student of his come to him
who was the representative for Arkansas,
for that district in Arkansas,
and he said to Fulbright,
"You always told us that
democracy won't work
"unless the best and the
brightest run for office.
"Now I'm gonna make you put
your money where your mouth is.
"You are gonna have to take my office,
"or run for my office,
because I'm leaving it
"at the end of this term."
And he thought about it, and
he went to his wife Betty,
and they agreed, and he ran for it
and he got the office as a legislator.
Within a year--
- And that is to the National Congress?
- To the National Congress.
- [Harry] Right.
- He was in the House of Representatives.
And within a year, the Senate,
one of the two Senate
offices was about to open
because the senator said
he was not going to run
in the next election.
And immediately a man that
Fulbright had no respect for
said he was going to run
for that Senate seat.
He thought, "I can't let that happen.
"I can't work under that man."
So he ran for the Senate
seat and he got it.
So he was only for one year in the House.
- Now, we're gonna talk
about his contribution
to international education.
But I think I wanna first start with his
role as a visionary with
regard to US foreign policy
and America's role in the world.
We'll get to the international
education part in a moment.
So, his situation was
complicated in the sense
that he came from a southern state,
and to get re-elected, he
was not in the forefront
on civil rights.
- (laughs) He had to
stay in the background,
or he wouldn't have been re-elected.
Back then that was the case.
- And so his personal views
must have been very different
from what he had to do as a politician.
Now he ultimately becomes chairman
of the foreign relations committee.
And his expertise is really
on international relations,
and that's really where--
- Exactly correct.
- He made his mark.
His vision,
His vision was one in which
he saw that America and the US
had to restrain itself,
because it had so much power.
- Had to restrain itself
in terms of the power part.
But had to reach out a great deal
in terms of international relations.
Because this was, this is a huge country
with water on two sides.
And so it's not as if
you're living in Europe
and saying, oh yes, you know,
if it's Tuesday this must be Belgium,
and next I'm gonna drive four hours
and be in another country.
And the mentality is hugely different.
- And his, did he ever talk to you about
his role with regard to opposing
the Vietnam war and those--
- Oh, it killed him, yes.
- And when you say killed
him, in what sense?
'Cause he was so frustrated?
- Yes.
- [Harry] That in other words his vision.
- Told him that this
was all wrong and so on.
- [Harriet] That's right, that's correct.
- And did he,
he kept at it and he,
the Fulbright hearings
of course are one of the,
it's really where the establishment
embraces the consciousness
of the people in the street
who are opposing the war.
- And he had to do that so, so carefully.
- Yeah, in what sense, I mean--
- Well, in the sense that he
couldn't come blasting out
with, you know, criticisms and feelings
of what we really should be doing.
He had to do it by questioning.
He had to do it by
holding infinite hearings
in the Senate, and bringing young people,
John Kerry being one of them,
to talk about, you know, views on--
- So in other words, he was very conscious
of the need for a discovery process.
- [Harriet] Correct, correct, yes.
- And so through questioning and so on,
I guess his Oxford education
must have really helped him.
- Tremendous.
- [Harry] Yeah.
- I don't think he could
have done that without it.
- Now did that affect
him at home in Arkansas?
Was Arkansas such a provincial place that,
in a way, this public vision
for America's global role
had a negative impact in Arkansas?
- It had an initial negative impact,
but again, he was always
reaching out to his own state.
And I'll never forget a
letter that he received
fairly far into the process which said,
"I never voted for you.
'I'd never lost an
opportunity to denigrate you.
"But, I'm slowly beginning to realize
"the real profound understanding you have
"and the rightness of your position."
And he said, "Make no mistake, my friend.
"When we all meet our
maker and others come
"and we'll be standing our shoulders,
"the person standing on your shoulders
"will be a little higher than others."
And I thought that was a beautiful letter.
- As a Fulbright ambassador,
later in your career,
you had the opportunity to visit Vietnam.
Not with the senator, but
talk about that experience
and the recognition you were given.
- And I hasten to add I was an unofficial,
I didn't have that title, but I was
an unofficial ambassador, you might say.
And it was an extraordinary experience
because I was greeted with open arms
because of the senator's work.
And I went to classrooms and spoke to them
and got wonderful.
But at one point I was
sitting with a group
describing certain things, and suddenly
down the steps came this
little, very energetic man
and he sat next to me and
he grabbed my shoulders
and he kissed me on both
cheeks, and he said,
"Senator Fulbright, he was the only one
"who understood the Vietnamese people."
And it was General Giap.
- Who was the architect of the Vietnam--
- [Harriet] Exactly.
- War on the Vietnamese side.
- Yes.
- [Harry] That must have been a moving--
- It was amazing.
- Experience.
And he just recently passed away.
- Yes, he did, yes he did.
He was an extraordinary man.
- Back to the Congress,
this courageous stand by Senator Fulbright
really affected his relationship
with President Johnson,
who I think he had been close
to in an earlier period.
- [Harriet] Yes.
- And actually sponsored the
Gulf of Tonkin Resolution.
- [Harriet] Right.
- But then he came to realize that he
had been had by the president.
- That's correct, yes.
- [Harry] So their relation soured then.
- It very much soured, yes.
- And what about his fellow congressmen?
I mean, was this an educational process
for his fellow Senators, also?
- Some of them, yes, and some of them
spoke to him privately, but publicly they,
they had to keep their
distance, that's very true.
- So what were, when you would talk
to Senator Fulbright about this,
what was his overall lesson
learned from that experience?
- Lesson for himself?
- [Harry] Yeah, for himself, yeah.
- It was, I think a
lesson that he basically,
deep down understood
even before, you know,
it was happening, but it was
just that people have to,
people have to understand
changes in the world
in a very slow, deliberative
and educational way.
You can't suddenly have an epiphany
and expect other people to follow.
- Now the other vision that
Fulbright brought to the table
came from his Rhodes Scholar experience.
That is, he came to see the importance.
On the one end--
- Yes.
- He saw the military power wasn't
the end all and be all,
but on the other hand,
what we now call soft power,
international education
was an instrument for
enhancing America's power
and changing the world.
- That is correct, and
during the second world war,
toward the end of the second world war,
he was in Congress by that time,
and he said, he stopped and he thought,
"Why are we in a world war
"within two generations of the first?
"This is insanity, this
is self-destruction."
And in deeply thinking about it,
and through his experiences
as Rhodes Scholar
and world traveler, he
realized it has to do
with basic misunderstanding
and lack of knowledge
of other people, and
how do we overcome that?
And that was his legislation creating
the Fulbright scholarship,
that's why it happened.
- And this was very early.
- [Harriet] Oh, yes.
- This would have been in the 40s?
- [Harriet] - '46 was when the--
- So he was in Congress?
- Yes, he was, and '46 was when the first
legislation was signed to
establish this scholarship
and he, he was a very wiley politician,
because that piece of legislation
had no money attached.
And so,
(both laugh)
when it went through people looked,
other Congressmen looked,
no money, oh who cares.
And so immediately it passed.
Then he said, "How am
I going to pay for it?"
And a few months later
coming across his desk
was a piece of legislation allowing for,
or actually promoting the sale of
all the amazing amounts
of, not just munitions,
but jeeps and medical
supplies, etc., etc.,
that were lying all over the
world where we were fighting.
And it was, we were going to sell it
to the country where it lay.
And he thought, "I've got it."
And at the bottom of that
piece of legislation,
he wrote, "These funds shall be limited
"to the underwriting of
the international education
"exchange program."
And that was the beginning
of how we paid for it.
- So it's a case where, in one sense,
people didn't know what
he was doing (chuckles).
- No, and he was very happy (laughs).
- So it was kind of
under the table, covert,
whatever the word is.
- So true, and six months after that,
you know after that passed
and it was all in place
and there was nothing that
could be done to change it
without really uproar,
a senator came to him
and shook his finger in
his face and he said,
"Young man, if I had
known what you were up to
"I would have put it so fast to stop.
"Don't you realize how horrible it is
"to expose our fine young boys and girls
"to those dangerous foreign isms."
- And was the original conception
sending American abroad, Americans abroad?
- That's right, Fulbright.
- But not yet bringing foreigners here.
- That's correct.
- [Harry] Right.
- That came when everybody realized
what the tremendous benefit it was.
- Fulbright's idea was that,
if you go abroad, and you
experience these cultures,
that, on the one hand, the
other country's citizen
will gain a kind of respect and affection
for America and American mores,
and on the other hand, the American will
learn about the foreign country
and come back as a teacher or--
- Yes, and realize that the
differences are not evil
or wrong, they're differences.
And that we can live with them.
And as a matter of fact,
if we do live with them,
we become better people.
- And so how many years
has the Fulbright program
been in existence?
- Well the first legislation
was signed in '46.
- And the first Fellows were in '47?
- In '48, the first Fellows
went in both directions,
to the east and to the west.
- Was it only academics and professors?
- At that time.
And from all disciplines?
- [Harriet] Yes.
- From all disciplines.
- And then when did the
program evolve into one
that would bring foreigners here?
- That actually was a few years later
when other countries realized
what a tremendous benefit it was
and they began to offer to
contribute to the program
in their country.
And I think by this
time it's something like
14 different countries actually contribute
more than half the funds necessary
for the Fulbright
program in their country.
- And you mentioned earlier that
when you became involved
with the Fulbright program,
it was, part of your job was building
a historical record of all of the Fellows.
- First the Americans.
- What were the numbers like, I mean,
over the years,
approximately how many people
have participated in this program.
- Oh Lord, when I was doing
it, which was years ago,
it was over 300,000, so
obviously the number,
I haven't kept up with the exact figures.
But it's probably more than
half a million by this time
- Right, and presumably the
sale of the military goods
expired,
- [Harriet] Oh yes.
- Sometime shortly that--
- They expired about seven or eight years,
six, seven, eight years after that.
- Right, and at that
point, was the Congress
willing to fund it?
- Yes, yes, by that time
they really understood
what the benefits were.
- So this became an instrument
of American soft power--
- [Harriet] Correct.
- At the height of the
cold war, cause this--
- [Harriet] Correct.
- Really started before the cold war,
at the very beginning.
What did Fulbright see as
his greatest achievement?
Both the foreign policy vision that he
brought to the table, and this?
Or was this his favorite child?
- I think this was his favorite child.
Yes, it really was.
- Did he often meet with the
Fulbright Fellows themselves?
- Yeah, he did, and he
loved sitting around
a table with them.
That was a real pleasure because
he got real conversation from them.
- Now in the Clinton administration,
you were the chairman of the arts council.
- It was the arts and
humanities, yes it was the--
- And in that program the goal was
to bring private foundations
and the private sector
together with government
to support the arts
and the humanities.
- When I was there it was strictly
through the United States.
I talked about an international,
but I was too busy trying to (chuckles)
get the United States.
I just talked about it.
Subsequently, they not
only talked about it,
they did begin to spread
their wings abroad.
- To what extent has that knowledge
been applied to the Fulbright.
In other words, is there private support
in the United States for
Fulbright fellowships.
Or is the only source of new funding
the countries themselves?
- No, there is some private, especially
through colleges and universities
who understand what, what a
tremendous benefit it is, yes.
- Now, the world that, which you were
a foreign exchange student, and the world
where Fulbright's vision was founded
is a different world than
the world that we have today.
- [Harriet] Totally.
- On the one hand, there's
a decline of American power,
the rise of the others.
And on the other hand, there is
the diversity that we have on a campus
like Berkeley, and really
now all universities are
so diverse that often the
Anglo-Saxon population,
- That's right.
- [Harry] Is a minority.
- [Harry] Among minorities.
- Yes.
- Basically and so on.
Students who go abroad can
Skype, can do face time,
can send emails.
So does this suggest that
the Fulbright program
has to change, and in what
ways would it have to change?
- I don't think so, you know.
I think that, and furthermore
the Fulbright program
started changing from the
time that it was first
instituted because of
the fact that there was
interest and therefore
interest in getting involved
in it as well from other countries,
and in supporting the program
through their own funding.
So it's been a constant evolution.
It's not just a sudden change.
- And so do you see any new goals
for international education?
I mean, in other words, is the vision one
that remains resilient?
Or have there been major adaptions
by the Fulbright program?
- Oh, I think that the adaptions
are not so much on the fundamental level,
but on the addition of, for instance,
disciplines that didn't even
exist when it first began,
exchanges with countries that
also perhaps didn't exist, or certainly
were not part of an
international community.
That's where the constant change comes.
- What does, what happens
to, I assume there's
still Congressional funding.
- Oh yes.
- Yeah.
So what happens in a
world where the vision
of a faction of a party is
so narrow, so provincial,
that if this faction were
running the State of Arkansas,
back when Senator
Fulbright went to Oxford.
They wouldn't let him go.
Because in other words,
he would ,(laughing)
as one of the best and the brightest,
he would be tainted by
what he might experience.
I mean, it's a very different,
I mean it's not the entire
environment in the Congress.
But it--
- Definitely, yeah.
- A faction that has used its veto power
to, in some distorted way,
impose its vision on the country.
- But I don't think that
the international education
is something that they have focused on.
- [Harry] Yet.
- Yet, you're quite right.
If they do, I'm gonna start getting up
on a soap box (laughs).
- [Harry] Right.
- But it's not, for them,
it's not important enough
to start trying to block.
- What would Senator Fulbright
think of all of this?
If he were now on the
one hand, he was aware
of people in his own
district, in his own state
who basically he couldn't
confront on certain issues.
But (chuckles) it's almost obvious.
But is there some particular perspective
that he would bring that,
knowing him so well and so on?
- Well, there's one
little story that I think
I need to tell you because a lot of this
he treated with humor, in trying to.
And that was he was sitting
with one of his constituents
and they were talking about
the venal and horrible
and Satanic influences of those Commies,
and how awful it was and what we've gotta
do something about it.
At that point Fulbright looked
at him, and then he got up.
And he said, "Commies?"
And he started looking
under the furniture.
(laughing)
And he said, "Commies, where are they?"
- It must be very hard
for somebody like Senator Fulbright,
who's also a politician in some sense,
part of his constituency is,
he's able to see so much more
than the narrowest, most provincial,
- Um hmm.
- Visionaries in his own,
how did he deal with that?
I mean, is it, you obviously
try to bring them along.
As you said, he tried
to bring along senators
to his vision of the Vietnam war.
But, he must have developed
a remarkable set of skills.
- I think those skills
were factual material.
Now, when he'd get these barrages at him,
he'd say, "Now what harm
have they really done?
"What are they focusing on
that is hitting at our hearts?"
And then he would describe
the fact that they weren't.
- That is the Congress.
- Very specifically.
Not just Commies, but other people
who were trying to--
- So it's a question of
going back to his role
as an educator, to sort
of focus on the facts.
What is the reality
versus what are bad ideas
about the reality?
- [Harriet] Yes.
- And he tried to do it gently.
He was never a proponent
of hitting a person
square in the face.
- So he lived his educational philosophy.
- Yes he did, yes he really did.
- Now he, President Clinton awarded him
the medal of freedom.
- [Harriet] That's correct.
- And this must have
been a moving occasion.
- Oh amazing, yes obviously I
attended and it was amazing,
and it was very emotional
for both of them.
- Now, and Clinton had
worked for him, right,
in his office and his (mumbles) office.
- That's correct.
- [Harry] And they didn't agree
about everything back then.
- It was so funny, they didn't.
But he was, he would do whatever he could,
not only to help in the
offices, but to be close to him.
And so he immediately
offered to be his driver.
And he would drive him
to his various meetings
around the city, or, if it was here.
And he would talk as he was driving.
And I remember one time Bill smiling
and talking about one time when he said,
"Young man, you might be
really good at politics,
"but you are a lousy driver.
"Do you realize the sun is
on the wrong side of this car
"for where we're going?"
(laughing)
- So Clinton was already politicking.
- Oh he was.
- [Harry] Yeah.
- So climbing up into the light.
So looking back at your
career, your experiences
with the Fulbright program,
what advice would you
give students as they're
preparing for their future?
- I would say that an
international experience
is more important than ever.
Also higher education is
more important than ever.
So nowadays, a BA is more and more often
not the last degree that you
need, it is a higher one.
- What do you see as
the inspirational story
of Senator Fulbright that
they should be aware of?
- That's a really interesting question,
'cause there are so many stories (laughs).
- But the big picture, account of him.
I mean, it's about courage and knowledge
and fighting the good fight.
- Fighting the good fight without,
without fight-ing, but educating.
- That's important.
- Yes.
- And that's what he was trying
to do in the Vietnam era.
- That's exactly correct, yes.
- Well, Mrs. Fulbright, I
wanna thank you very much
for coming on our program, and for being
the first harver, Harv-est lecturer,
for distinguished women.
- I can't thank you enough for having me.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation With History.
(gentle fun music)